[Applaudissements]
lincoln était riyom light cone polka
teaser d'obstacles malo cancale
cambistes dix ans après leur apparition
les crypto monnaie se développe à une
vitesse exponentielle et ceux qui ont
parié sur leur succès dès le début
suivent les mêmes courbes de croissance
c'est le cas de ledger nouveautés dans
de la sécurité numérique
implantée à new york singapour paris et
nous dans le cher à vierzon
[Musique]
bonjour à tous je m'appelle david ballon
j'ai 32 ans je suis co fondateur de
ledger est actuellement directeur du
site de vierzon j'habite à vierzon
depuis quasiment 13 ans je suis arrivé
ici pendant mes études c'est vendredi
freeware jean tee shirts les codes
vestimentaires des entreprises coulent
et moderne
david ballon n'a pas besoin de costumes
pour impressionner ses interlocuteurs
ces commerçants et entrepreneurs
vierzonnais savent qu'ils ont devant eux
un acteur majeur de la nouvelle économie
disposait à leur expliquer dans une
master class les secrets de sa réussite
alors qu'est-ce que victoire c'est du
cash en c1 ces liquides en peer-to-peer
c'est à dire que vous échangez se
cachent de monsieur à monsieur b
directement d'ordinateur à ordinateur
il faut de solides notions en
informatique pour comprendre dans le
détail le fonctionnement des crypto
monnaye pas besoin de diplôme en
revanche pour voir que la valeur du
bitcoin a augmenté de 70 % entre janvier
et février
ce pied un site déjà un commerçant de
vierzon à les accepter
je pense que dans les années qui vont
suivre le les crypto monnaie ils vont le
prendre une part entière à notre société
et du coup les banques commencent à s'y
intéresser aussi donc je pense que nous
on a été peut-être précurseur en
acceptant cette ce moyen de paiement
mais du coup dans l'avenir à mon avis
presque tout le monde va l'accepter
[Musique]
on peut aujourd'hui payer son canapé à
vierzon en bitcoin c'est une étape mais
ce qui affole les marchés en ce début
d'année c'est surtout l'annnonce du
groupe tesla fondé par le milliardaire
elon musk hier effectivement tesla a
annoncé qu'ils avaient investi 1,5
milliard de dollars dans le bitcoin sous
tout simplement sur la forme de réserves
pour protéger une partie leur patrimoine
et bien ce matin on l'a on l'a ressenti
puisque durant la nuit nos ventes ont
quasiment doublé le travail aujourd'hui
et le double de ce qui était attendu
la clé du succès de ledger c'est
justement une sorte de clé usb
équipé d'une carte à puce et d'un code
secret qui en font un coffre-fort
numérique a failli il permet de mettre
en sécurité
tous les types de crypto monnaie deux
millions et demi d'exemplaires ont été
vendus depuis la création du groupe et
les prévisionnels sont régulièrement
dépassé des niveaux qu'on n'a jamais vus
annoncé c'est en fait c'est des 'black
friday' tous les gens associés dans la
sphère dès ses débuts
eric larchevêque a laissé la direction
du site de vierzon un avis de ballons
mais il vient régulièrement à l' usine
en voisin depuis sa propriété de sologne
pour surveiller l'évolution de ses
actifs
investir au bon moment et au bon endroit
c'est une tradition chez les
l'archevêque puisque sa famille a
longtemps possédé une grande fabrique de
porcelaine à l'époque où cette industrie
faisait les beaux jours de vierzon j'ai
passé mon enfance à vierzon j'étais à
l'école à vierzon et ensuite je suis
allé à paris et j'avais oublié on va
dire vierzon parce que je faisais mes
affaires pourquoi est ce qu'on a décidé
d'y rester et d'y mettre nos sites
implantés de façon aussi importante
c'est parce qu'on avait besoin d'avoir
une activité vraiment production
logistique quelque chose plus le redire
d'industriels vous pouvez certainement
pas faire ça à paris ça n'avait aucun
sens et vierzon et est idéalement placé
pour le faire puisque d'un point de vue
logistique on est au coeur de tous il ya
de la place
je sais pas si c'est à lévis mais on est
numéro un en volume
france etats unis chez bhf on est le
client numéro un là ils vont ouvrir un
bar croatie ont fait partie des cinq
clients principaux sur ce on va faire du
vierzon new york
en 24 heures quatre pour répondre au
boom des commandes ledger orkut
régulièrement ils seront bientôt une
soixantaine de salariés à vierzon et 250
sur l'ensemble des sites et des emplois
sont aussi créés chez les sous traitants
cette machine qui permet d'emballer les
colis a été conçu sur mesure à quelques
kilomètres de là chez jbeli entreprise
spécialisée dans la robotique qui avant
travail et surtout pour l'automobile et
la défausse aujourd'hui on leur fournit
des machines
spécial donc personnaliser à leurs
besoins on a déjà fourni 2 ça c'est la
deuxième après le but c'est de leur
fournit toute une ligne de production
si c'est l'oeuvre le but de produire
localement tout l'apathie électronique
dans quelques mois
jbe quittera le petit village de
thénioux pour s'installer à vierzon en
face de ledger dans un parc
technologique prévu pour accueillir
d'autres entreprises de l'économie
numérique et leurs futurs salariés sont
déjà en formation dans cette école
ouverte en septembre dernier est
calibrée pour recevoir 500 élèves qui
apprendront à concevoir des logiciels
je viens du monde de starter je viens
pas du vent d'enseignement et j'étais
pas très satisfaits de la qualité des
formations qui existaient et je me suis
un peu je me suis posé la question de
savoir aujourd'hui un google apple
microsoft
enfin les ce qu'on appelle les gars
femme qu'est ce qu'ils cherchent comme
profil et qui est-ce qui forment à ces
profils n'a pas vraiment de
l'enseignement qui forment à ces profils
là et nous on est conçu pour satisfaire
les besoins de ses grands éditeurs de
logiciels
[Musique]
après cinq années d'études intégralement
en anglais ces élèves seront
opérationnels pour intégrer les géants
de la tech
à l'autre bout du monde comme au bout de
la rue signe que quelque chose est en
train de changer dans le paysage
économique vierzonnais c'est sans doute
la ville de la région où l'on croise le
plus 2d cela
david belle en a une car j'avais quand
on a une la femme d'eric archevêque en a
une
moi j'en ai deux non mais j'ai bien hâte
à vierzon mai donc oui oui sûrement il
ya d'autres assureurs quand on a acheté
une depuis tout à l'heure
à suivre encore le point et coup avec
david de l'autre bonjour david bonjour
ça mais bonjour à tous je parle ce matin
de ce fameux peak coyne effectivement
puisque elon musk que se ferment et le
milliardaire a investi massivement dans
l'équipe de modèles l'a propulsé de
bitcoin à des records jamais le
numérique c'est un peu le renouveau de
vierzon c'est la revanche des villes
moyennes avec des entreprises comme
ledger qui sont des quasi licorne c'est
à dire d entreprise valorisée à plus
d'un milliard de dollars qui sont
implantés à vierzon parce que l on
trouvait aussi à vierzon un accueil
favorable et un écosystème propice à l
époque où ses ingénieurs travaillaient
sur un projet lié à la musique en ligne
avec un chiffre d'affaires très modeste
les futurs créateurs de ledger ont été
accueillis dans le centre d'innovation
de la ville quand ils se sont orientés
ensuite vers le secteur beaucoup plus
rentable des crypto monnaie vierzon en a
logiquement profité ledger s'est
installé avec un certain nombre
d'emplois avec une production
aujourd'hui qui qui concerne le monde
entier puisqu'il envoie dans je ne sais
plus 150 ou 160 pays différents leurs
produits et puis ça donne à vierzon une
visibilité comme une petite la petite
silicon valley de la région centre
puisque vous voyez le premier campus
numérique qui va être labellisé y
compris par l'éducation nationale sera à
vierzon et donc pour nous c'est quelque
chose de très important ville
industrielle puis ville sinistrée par la
fermeture de ses usines
vierzon qui a élu et réélu à maire
communiste a paradoxalement l'occasion
de rebondir grâce à des monnaies
numérique conçu pour échapper au
contrôle d etat et grâce à la
spéculation financière
nous on encourage rien ici ils ne se
créent pas de cryptome n'est à ledger
ledger ne fait que la sécurisation des
crypto monnaie ce qui est pas tout à
fait la même chose et après le travail
de ledger je pense à terme sera la
sécurisation toutes les transactions de
données donc je crois que ledger fera le
pack il se rendre à faire après vous
savez quand aux cryptes omnès si ledger
n'était pas à vierzon il serait
peut-être juste à côté
donc autant les avoir avertis comme la
courbe du bitcoin passé en quelques mois
de 8000 à 50 mille dollars
les effectifs des entreprises dépendant
des crypto monnaie connaissent une
croissance continue et si la spéculation
financière et est créatrice d'emplois
c'est le revers de la médaille vu du
côté le plus là quand vous voulez
investir dans les cryptes monnaie vous
ne savez pas comment faire
pas de problème les actionnaires de
ledger ont pensé à tout il y a quelques
années ils ont aussi créé une société de
conseils financiers
ses effectifs ont doublé ces six
derniers mois et elle aurait attiré plus
de 40 mille clients en 2020 pour en 2016
on était encore sur la clientèle
beaucoup de particuliers plutôt geek
plutôt jeune et depuis 3 4 ans la
structure change complètement
on a de plus en plus d'entreprises qui
souhaitent placer la trésorerie ou faire
des investissements envie de cueille
notamment et puis des particuliers qui
sont plutôt sur une logique de
construction et de diversification
patrimoniale donc des personnes plus
âgées avec un fort patrimoine qui
souhaitent profiter de la performance
des crypto et qui viennent diversifié 5
10% leur capital en bitcoin est était
rien
maintenant je vais avoir un accès donc à
mon portefeuille
voilà je peux faire des opérations
achats et vend sa vie à obtenir
mon ordinateur directement depuis la
plateforme commune a ouvert sa
directement les opérations d'achat et
vente et sur le ledger si vous souhaitez
switcher ou faire des arbitrages
vous pouvez me contacter en réalisera le
transfère directement sur la plateforme
et à ce moment là on fera le l'arbitrage
plus les cours du bitcoin augmente plus
les acheteurs investissent dans ce qui
semble être une bonne affaire
et si la bulle un jour se dégonflait les
économistes ne peuvent pas prédire
l'avenir mais il constate que les
cryptes monnaies sont devenus en cette
période comme lors des valeurs refuges
même s'il est paradoxalement ces
monnaies se porte bien puisque leurs
prix augmentent le fait que leur prix
augmente paradoxalement ne sont
peut-être pas un très bon signe sur ce
qui est rendre van dyck et ce qui était
revendiqué en tout cas à propos de ces
monnaies s'avère qu'elles soient des
véritables monnaie puisque si leur prix
augmente ça veut dire que les gens
spéculent dessus s'en servent comme
réserve de valeur beaucoup plus que
comme comme de l'argent on utilise pour
des transactions
jusque là rien à freiner le
développement du bitcoin ni les
critiques sur son mode de production
très énergivores qui oblige de grands
calculateur à fonctionner 24 heures sur
24 et 7 jours sur 7 dans des hangars
qu'il faut climatisé ni les questions
sur la sécurité des placements en 2020
des hackers ont réussi à pirater à
negage heures un million de données
clients qui ont ensuite reçu des mails
de menaces mais leur patrimoine n'a pas
été mise en danger
vu les chiffres de vente la confiance
semble toujours là et tous les espoirs
sont permis
le véritable objectif de ledger c'est de
rentrer au cac40 et pourquoi le cac 40
c'est à dire on veut faire de ledger un
véritable champion industriel et
technologique mondial donc les ambitions
sont vraiment très très importante et
c'est pour ça que ledger réinvesti
absolument tout ce qu'elle peut gagner
dans la recherche et développement dans
la création de nouveaux produits dans la
création de nouvelles technologies parce
que
ledger a vraiment pour ambition d'être
un géant technologique mondiale si
possible pourquoi pas au même titre
qu'un qu'un google ou amazon l'avenir du
groupe dépendra de sa capacité à garder
un temps d'avancé sur la concurrence
anticiper et réagir vite aux attentes du
marché pour continuer à encaisser les
bénéfices pour l'instant ledger joue et
gagne
[Applaudissements]